le brésil a dépassé ce vendredi le seuil
des 600 mille victimes du coc vite 19 en
hommage une ong brésilienne a suspendu
six ans mouchoir blanc sur la plage de
copacabana à rio dé janeiro symbolisant
les familles des victimes du col et 19
une épidémie encore loin d'être sous
contrôle dans le pays selon certains
spécialistes les détails d augusta
lunardi si depuis sao paulo
le brésil vient de dépasser le seuil des
600 mille morts dus qu'aux vite 19 mai
la pandémie commencent enfin à reculer
dans le pays malgré la gestion au
chaotique de l'épidémie par le
gouvernement la vaccination elle montre
un faon ses effets cette nouvelle phase
s'accompagne d'une chute est
significatif de décès à moins de 500 par
jour en moyenne contre plus de 2000 au
mois de juin et si la vaccination a été
lente en raison du départ tardif de la
campagne ou encore de nombreuses
ruptures de stock aujourd'hui plus de 45
% de la population a reçu les deux doses
du vaccin un score honorable que
beaucoup de pays peuvent envier atteint
1 dépit des réticences du président
jaillir molson a rod ya multiplié les
déclarations empreintes de scepticisme
sur le vaccin jusqu'à l'outrance parfois
comme leur fils a déclaré que le vaccin
pouvait je cite transformer les gens
crocodile à cause de ses effets
secondaires et qui serait le dernier
brésilien à être vaccinés fortement
critiqué pour sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire jaillir nationale voit sa
popularité lourdement chuter des
milliers de brésiliens ont manifesté
samedi dernier pour demander la
destitution du président et des lancers
principalement les conséquences
économiques de la crise sanitaire les
hausses du coût de la vie mais le chef
d'état ne s'est pas exprimé sur le sujet
et à un an seulement de la
présidentielle un sondage réalisé mi
septembre donnait 26 % à jaillir au
dollar au premier tour contre 44% pour
l'ancien président lula